[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهد في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
تحديدا
النصفي التي توصفه بالحاسمه
الى باكستان التي تعيش على واقع سيجالي
محاوله اغتيالي عمران خان الفاشله وترقب
لمسيره احتجاجيه الثلاثاء تطالب بانتخابات
مبكرا
الى ايران
سفير النرويج لديها الاحتجاج على ما سمتها
تعليقات تعتبر تدخل في شؤونها رئيس
البرلمان النرويجي
في مواضيع الحصاد
بعد تقارير عن دعوه
الكريم لم يقولوا ان روسيا مازال تبدي
استعدادها لاجراء محادثات كيف ترد لم نرفض
التفاوض مع روسيا ونريد التحدث مع خليفه
بوتن والصحف الامريكيه تكشف عن اتصالات
سريه بين موسكو واشنطن على مستوى العالم
[موسيقى]
على واقع منورات هي الاكبر على الاطلاق
بين كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
كوريا الشماليه تتوعد بمسمتها اجراءات
عسكريه حازمه وساحقه وتتحدث عن تنفيذ
طلعات قتاليه شملت 500 طائره واتفاق بين
واشنطن وتوكيو وسول على توجيه رساله حاسمه
وموحده ردا على ما وصفت باستفزازات بيونجا
في الانتخابات التشديد النصفي للكونغرس
الديمقراطيون في معركه لحظات الاخيره
لانقاذ اغلبيتهم في مجلس النواب والشيوخ
والجمهوريون يخوضون تحركات قضائيه تتسارع
لابطال الاف بطاقات التصويت عبر البريد في
ولايه المتاحه
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصات من
الرقميه ناقشنا نشر الون ماسك الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه تويتر قواعد تدوين جديده
في المنصه قال انها ستتطور بمرور الوقت من
ابرز التغييرات على قواعد الاستخدام الحضر
الدائم لحساباتي منتحلي الشخصيه ايلين
ماسك قال امس الاحد ان مهمه منصه التواصل
هي ان تصبح المصدر الاكثر دقه للمعلومات
لاستطلاع رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما الذي سيتاثر
بتعديل قواعد التدوين المرتقبه في منصه
تويتر وقد جاءت الاجابات على النحو
التاليه نحو سبعه 77% قالوا ان مضمونا
محتوى سيتاثر بينما راى 23% ان شكل
المحتوى سيتاثر بتعديل قواعد التدوين
المرتقبه في تويتر
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا في منصات الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصات
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
وسط غضب من زياره مزمعه لوزير بريطانيا
الى تايوان بجين تحذر تايبي مما سميته
التواطؤ مع القوه الاجنبيه للاستقلال
[موسيقى]
اعلن الكريم ان روسيا لا تزال منفتحه على
المحادثات مع اوكرانيا
عن اجراء مستشار الامن القومي
اتصالات سريه مع الجانب الروسي اعتبر
الكرملين ان وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه
والامريكيه ترد الكثير من مواصفها
بالمعلومات الكاذبه
وكانت الصحيفه قالت ان جيك سلفن اجرى
اتصالات سريه مع كبار مساعدين رئيس بوتن
في محاوله للحد من مخاطر نشوب صراع اوسع
حول اوكرانيا ولتحذير موسكو من مغبه لجوء
بوتين للسلاح النووي او البيولوجي
هذا وقال مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني اكياس
لن ترفض ابدا التفاوض وان موقفها معروف
داعيا القوات الروسيه الى الانسحاب اول من
اوكرانيا ثم يمكن الحديث بعد ذلك عن
التفاوض
تشكل دعوه الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا الى
التفاوض مع روسيا تحولا لافتا في الموقف
الامريكي الذي كان يتسم بالتشدد وبالاصرار
على تحقيق ما وصفه الرئيس الامريكي بالنصر
الاستراتيجي على الرئيس بلادي مير بوتن
ويبدو ان الحرب في اوكرانيا كشاني كل حرب
قد خلقت حيثيات جديده لعل اختارها التقارب
الروسي الصيني الذي قد يشكل نواه لمحور
جديد لوضع حد للهيمنه الامريكيه على
العالم كما نتداعيه الحرب الاقتصاديه على
الغرب اصبحت تشكل هي الاخرى مهددا لتماسك
المعسكر الغربي تجاه الحرب التي قد يطول
امدها فوق قدره الجميع تقرير فوزي بشرى
قبيل الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا كانت
الولايات المتحده اكثر الاصوات في ضروره
الاستعداد لها ثم لما اندلعت الحرب كانت
الاكثر انخراطا فيها تسليحا وتمويلا من
بين جميع الدول الغربيه الان يبدو ان لغه
جديده تصدر عن واشنطن اسمعتها لاوكرانيا
سرا وتكفلت صحيفه الوطن
فكان الطلب لاوكرانيا
فلا بد من المفاوضات مع روسيا لاظهار
انفتاحكم على هذا المسار ولو من اجل طمانت
عالم طلبه حياته في اكثر من بلد بسبب
الحرب
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جاك سوبرمان
التقى الرئيس الاوكرانيه
الذي كان اخره مبلغ 400 مليون دولار وهو
ما رفع جمله المساعدات الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا الى اكثر من 18 مليار دولار منذ
الحرب ومع الدعم سيكون الطالب
الروس
والتحول في الموقف الامريكي اذا لم يكن
امرا تكتكيا عابرا يهدف الى مزيد من تعريه
روسيا كقوه غاشمه تمارس ارهابا وغزو
واحتلالا لاراضي اوكرانيا فانه لا يعدم
ايضا ما يجعله تحولا مرتبط بصميم المصالح
الامريكيه وفي مقدمتها استدامه الهيمنه
بوصف امريكا القوه العظمى في العالم
عسكريا واقتصاديا
نظر تحول المزاج ظهرت قبل اسبوعين عندما
طالب 30 عضو في الكونغرس الرئيس الامريكي
بتغيير مقاربته للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا بالبحث والعمل على تحقيق تسويه
سلميه وجدل النواب انهم مؤتمنون على اموال
دافع الضرائب الامريكي ولا يرون الذهاب في
مواصله استنزاف هذه الاموال بالخطه
الرشيده وهناك خشيه من ان الرئيس اذا لم
يفعل ذلك مختارا فقط يجد نفسه مقره عليه
اذا قدر للجمهوريين ان يغير معادله القوه
في الكونجرس بعد الانتخابات النصفيه لكن
ما هو اخطر من كل ذلك هو ان الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا كشفت عمهادات متحديات حقيقيه
تواجه الولايات المتحده فمن جهه هناك
دائما التهديد النووي الذي شكل في مرحله
جزء من خطاب الحرب خاصه بعد اعلان موسكو
انها لن توفر شيئا مما في يدها من اذا تم
تحديد مصالحها وسلامه اراضيها وهذا تحديد
يحمل الولايات المتحده مسؤوليه اكثر اتجاه
حلفائها الاوروبيين الموجودين في عين
العاصفه النوويه اذا قامت وبذر هذا
الاحتمال يشكل دافعا قويا للاوروبيين
لمراجعه اعتمادهم الكامل على الولايات
المتحده بل ربما حملهم على الاتجاه شرقا
كما فعل المستشار الالماني بزيارته
الاخيره للصين انها المراجعه التي
اقتضضتها ايضا ازمه الطاقه حيث وقع
الانكشاف الاوروبي الاستراتيجي في مساله
تتصل بمطلوبات عيش المواطن الاوروبي
ولكثيلين بدله السياسه الامريكيه متصله
بالحرب كما لو انها قوه تنشط في تجنيد
الخصوم وتجميعهم
فجزء من زياده مفاعيل التقارب الروسي
الصيني المتطوره باتجاه اي يكون نواه لحلف
يضم المغبونين من السياسه الامريكيه اصبح
امرا مشهودا والولايات المتحده وجدت نفسها
مواجهه بمهددات الاستراتيجيات ظاهره ماثله
تمثلها روسيا واخرى كامله كالصين لكن
نموها الاقتصاديه والعسكريه المطارد ليس
مما يغيب عن رؤيه السياسيين والعسكريين
الامريكيين وهناك دوله كبيره ما استقامت
لها علاقه طبيعيه مع امريكا منذ اكثر من
43 عاما ايران ستجد نفسها في هذا المعسكر
كوريا الشماليه التي تقف على برنامج
النووي بعيد عن المراقبه وتتلاها باطلاق
الصواريخ القادره على حمل الرؤوس النوويه
كميه تلحى باطلاق الطائرات الورقيه هي
ايضا مهدد ظاهر وكامل هؤلاء جميعا ومعهم
دول لا تجاهروا بذلك يطلبون نظام عالميا
جديدا تنتهي فيه الهيمنه الامريكيه وتقوم
الاخطاب المتعدده لا تسلك العالم في نمط
ثقافي وسياسي واقتصاديا واحد ما تخرجت عنه
كنت مارقه ودعوه الاوكرانيين الى التفاوض
ربما كانت نزولا على اكراهات لا تسلم منها
حتى القوه العظمى
عضو مجلس الدومه الروسي ومن ماريلاند
عضو مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي السابق
مرحبا بكما سيد تشارلز ماذا افعل واهداف
هذه الاتصالات السريه من واشنطن مع موسكو
مواويل
مؤكد هو الاتصال او الاتصالات التي جرت
بين مسؤولين امريكيين وروسيا ركزت بشكل
حصري على مساله منع التصعيد
وتحذير روسيا ضد استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
والاتصالات ايضا تطرقت او السؤال يبقى اذا
كانت هذه الاتصالات توصلت الى مباحثات
بشان مفاوضات المستقبليه او حل بشان هدنا
او حل بشان الاراضي لا نعرف الاجابه عن
هذا السؤال بالنسبه الى اداره سوف تستمر
حتى اللحظه
بس سياستها السابقه اي ان اوكرانيا هي من
يتخذ القرار بشان الحرب لن نمضي على
اوكرانيا التفاوض ومتى يحصل ذلك
كوري هو ان كلا الطرفين روسيا واوكرانيا
ليس على استعداد لدخول الى مرحله
المفاوضات لربما في مازق مستقبلي مع حلول
الفصل الدراسي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تملي على
اوكرانيا التفاوض ولكن ايضا التسريبات
تقول بان واشنطن تطلب موقفا اكثر ليون من
اوكرانيا
للتفاوض في وقت يقول ال- ال- تقول وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه بان الجيش الاوكراني
يحقق تقدما على جبهتي خيرسون وايضا في
الشرق كيف نفهم هذا التوقيت
وانا هناك مساء المتعدده مطروح اول
بيئه الداخليه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تحدث في تقريركم عن 30 عضو
كونجرس من التقدم
وايضا الجمهوريون على الارجح سوف
يسيطر سوف يقومون بالسيطره على مجلس
النواب ويقولون ما من شك على بياض بنسبه
الى اوكرانيا لذلك الرئيس
يشعر بالضغط لكي يقول نعم الديبلوماسيه هي
جزء من استراتيجتنا
والسيدنسكي بنفسه قال كلا لن اتفاوض مع
بوتن اتفاوض مع روسيا فقط بعد ذهاب بوتان
هذا يضع الدول في موق صعب خصوصا فرنسا
والمانيا فرنسا والمانيا تدان العمل على
الحيز الدبلوماسيه وبالتالي هناك الجانب
الدبلوماسي والسياسه الداخليه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذا ما يدفع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بشكل اولي للتحدث مع
اوكرانيا ومعروس بشان الدبلومات
سريه بين واشنطن و موسكو
اوكرانيه
واغلب القوات
اوكرانيا تحصل على معدات واسلحه من امريكا
ولا احد يخفي هذا والاموال تاتي من اني
لولا الدعم الامريكي لما كان هناك نزاع
يذاكر اننا نقوم بعمليه عسكريه تتفق مع
القوانين الدوليه للدفاع عن مناطقها ولن
تروا تاريخيا اي اوكرانيا منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لذلك
بالطبع نحن نعتمد على ان علينا ان نتفق مع
امريكا بالنسبه لمناطق اوكرانيا لان
الولايات المتحده هم من همم نظمه واستفزه
حتى يبدا هذا النزاع اما بالنسبه
لتاريخ استخدام الاسلحه النوويه لما يذكر
اي
او مسؤول روسي عن استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
ولكن هذا فقط اذا تم كان لي ضبط امريكا
وليس اوكرانيا سد يبغيني طلب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من اوكرانيا بان يكون
لديها موقف اكثر مرونه في ما يتعلق
بالتفاوض هل هل ترون بان هذا يشكل ضغطا
امريكيا على اوكرانيا
اقول من جديد قال
النزاع بين امريكا وروسيا هم من استفزوا
هذا النزاع وهم من يمدوا الاسلحه ولو هذا
هذا
الدفاع العسكري الاوكراني لكان هذا وقف
منذ فتره طويله لا تستطيع القوه
الاوكرانيه ان تقف امام القوات الروسيه كل
الاسلحه هي الاجنبيه والقوات الاجنبيه
لذلك الحوار يجب ان يكون بين روسيا
وامريكا وهذا ما يحدث فعلا المشكله ان
الولايات المتحده لا ترى اي ذنب على
عاتقها في هذا النزاع انهم يدعمون النظام
احادي القطبيات تابع لامريكا وهذا لا
يجعلهم متوجهين للحوار مع روسيا لذلك نحن
نعتمد على اننا علينا ان همم نشكل قوات
الضغط على امريكا همم قوه ضغط عسكريه على
امريكا تفرض على امريكا العوده للحوار كما
قلته سابقا اوكرانيا لم تكن في التاريخ
بعد الحرب العالميه الثالثه دوله اا
قانونيه
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
موضوع اخر حيث تتعالى نبره التصعيد في شبه
جزيره الكوريه فقالت بيونجا ان اطلاق
الصواريخ البالستيه خلال الايام الماضيه
هو الرد الواضح على المناوره المشتركه
التي اجرتها كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات
المتحده جهتها نددت سول واشنطن وتوكيو في
بيان المشترك بالصواريخ الكوريه الشماليه
المزعزع للاستقرار في المنطقه يذكر ان
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه باسمي عاصفه
اليقظه انتهت السبت بعد تمديدها
الكوريتان اتهامات المتبادله بالاستفزاز
وتصعيدهم يحاكي حربا مؤجره
من التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه غير بعيد
عنها
انتهت عاصفه اليقظه السبت بدا ان الغبار
الذي سببته لن ينقشع قريبا
كوريا الشماليه سترد على العدو كما ورد
حرفيا في بين هيئه الاركان قالت ان تجارب
الصواريخ البالستيه الاخيره هي اجابه
واضحه لورشه الرسول بشان تدريبات الاسبوع
الماضي وحذرت من انه كل ما تواصلت تحركات
العسكريه لاستفزازيه فان الجيش الشعبي
الكوري سيواجههم بمزيد من الدقه والقسوه
وشهادههم خلال الايام الماضيه بعشرات
الصواريخ التي اطلقت ومنها صاروخ باريستي
عابر للقارات اثر الرعبا وتساؤلات كوريا
الجنوبيه هي التي قدمت تفاصيل عنه بلغ
مذاه نحو 760 كلم وارتفاعه اكثر من 1900
كم بسرعه 15 مره تحضر واشنطن وصول من ان
عمليات اطلاق الصواريخ قد تكون تمهيدا
لتجربه النوويه جديده ستكون السابعه في
تاريخ كوريا الشماليه استدعى الامر
استنفارا وعلى اكثر من صعيد لدى خصمك يومك
رومانسي
اتصال على
العمل على رساله حاسمه وموحده بشان
استفزازات كوريا الشماليه
وهذا الاستعراض للاسطول البحريه اليابانيه
الدولي قد يكون احدى تلك الرسائل الحدث هو
الاول من نوعه منذ سبع سنوات وشاركت فيه
12 دوله
رئيس الوزراء الياباني نبره مزج فيها
التحذير بالتحديد قال لك الشده انه ينبغي
لاستعداد لعصر يظهر فيه لاعبون يخالفون
القواعد ويستخدمون القوه والتهديدات
لتدمير السلام والامن في دول اخرى وعدم
تسريع المناقشات الجاريه بشان ما هو مطلوب
للدفاع عن شعبه من خلاله ابقاء كل
الخيارات مطروحات خيار تهدئه النفوس
والجيوش هو والابعد في المنطقه هذه الايام
[موسيقى]
حضرت الخارجيه الصينيه سلطات تايوان من
عواقب التواطئ مع القوات الاجنبيه السعيد
الاستقلال معتبره اننا ذلك محكوم عليه
بالفشل
البيان المشتركوا الاجتماعيه
حيوان
بشده اي شكل من اشكال التبادلات الرسميه
بين الدول ذات العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
وتايوان ومبدا الصين
لتنميه العلاقات الثنائيه بين الصين
والمملكه المتحده نحث الجانب البريطاني
على احترام سياده الصين والالتزام بمبدا
الصين الواحده ووقف اي شكل من اشكال
التبادلات الرسميه مع تايوان والتوقف عن
ارسال اشارات خاطئه الى القوه الانفصاليه
في تايوان
يفضل علينا من لندن الدكتور ستيف تشانغ
رئيس معهد الصين في جامعه لندن دكتور ماذا
نقرا في رساله وتوقيت زياره مزمعه لوزير
بريطاني الى تايبي
ان الوزير البريطاني في زيارته لتايوان
ليقوم بتنفيذ خطوه مخطط لها مسبقا
وبالتالي ما من اهميه لهذا التوقيت حيث ان
المملكه
المتحده تركت الاتحاد الاوروبي وتود ان
تعزز وترسخ العلاقات التجاريه مع عدد كبير
من البلدان وتايوان هي احدى هذه الدول هل
يسعى الغرب الى مواجهه مع الصين في تايوان
بتقدير الدكتور
كل تاكيدا المملكه المتحده لا تسعى لذلك
المملكه المتحده لا تود ان تدخل في حرب مع
الصين بشان اي مساله او اي ملف بما في ذلك
تايوان ولكن المملكه المتحده ترى انه من
حقها ان تبني العلاقات مع اي جهه اخرى وما
من سببا يدفع المملكه المتحده الى الشعور
بانه ليس باستطاعتها ان يكون لديها علاقه
تجاريه بقياده وزير التجاره
المراسلات هكذا تعتبرها استفزاز بالتالي
ما واجهت بان يواجه الغرب في هذه المرحله
الصين
ودفعها اكثر ربما للتحالف مع روسيا في وقت
تحاول اطراف اخرى في اوروبا بفك هذا الارت
الواقعي ما بين بجين وموسكو انطلاقا من
الحرب الاخيره روسيا والمستمره حتى الان
في اوكرانيا يا دكتور
ان يكون لدينا علاقات صعبه مع الصين ولكن
في الوقت نفسه لا يمكننا ان نقبل ان تملي
الصين علينا كيفيه اجراء العلاقات
الخارجيه او العلاقات التجاريه بالنسبه
للمملكه المتحده الامر لا يعود للصين كي
تقول للمملكه المتحده ما اذا كان
باستطاعتها ان تزوره
ليست فقط الزياره دكتور هي بيجين تعتبر
بان هذا المسار هو مسار سيؤدي الى همم
يعني تشجيع تايوان على الاستقلال وهو ما
ترفضه تماما الصين
تويتر
زياره في السياقه التجاريه لا تشجع وتوان
على الاستقلال ان المملكه المتحده تتبع
السياسه واضحه الصين واحده والصين الوحيده
التي تعترف بها هي جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
الحقيقه هي ان المملكه المتحده
تلقت هذا التحديث لانه في الوقت الراهن
العلاقه بين الصين والمملكه المتحده
متوتره بسبب امور حصلت في السابق ولكن في
الماضي عندما كانت العلاقات جيده ان هناك
وفود بريطانيه زارت تايوان ولكن لم يكن
هناك رد فعل من قبل بيجين وبالتالي اعتقد
ان الحكومه
الصينيه تتخذ موق متشددا في المملكه
المتحده بسبب التغير في على المستوى
الحكومى في المملكه المتحده وتغير الموقف
البريطاني بشكل عام تجاه الصين شكرا لك
الدكتور ستيف تشانغ رئيس معهد الصين في
جامعه لندن
[موسيقى]
بعد اقل من 24 ساعه يدلي عشرات ملايين
الامريكيين باصواتهم في انتخابات تاتي في
ظل الانقسام سياسيا حاد ماذا على المحك
نتحدث عن انتخابات التجديد النصفي
للكونغرس الامريكي وهي تنظم قبل عامين من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كل المقاعد وهي
435 مقعدا في مجلس النواب خاضعه للتنافس
وفي مجلس الشيوخ المؤلف من 100 مقعد تستمر
ولايه كل سنه سته اعوام وبالتالي فان اكثر
من ثلث اعضاء المجلس يجري تغييرهم او
التجديد لهم يوم غدا الثلاثاء اي 35
كذلك ينتخب الامريكيون عددا من حكام
الولايات ومجموعه من المسؤولين المحليين
الذين يقررون سياسه ولاياتهم فيما يتعلق
بمسائل مثل الاجهاض والتنظيمات البيئيه
وغيرها
ماذا عن لغه الارقام وفق استطلاعات الراي
الاخيره فان المعارضه الجمهوريه تمتلك
فرصه للفوز ب 10 الى خمسه وعشرين مقعدا
اضافيا في مجلس النواب وهي كافيه لتحصل
على الاغلبيه وفيما لا تزال استطلاعات
الراي اكثر غموضا فيما يتعلق بمجلس الشيوخ
لان يبدو ان الجمهورينا ايضا سيحققون
تقدما لفهم المشهد الانتخابي عشيه
الاقتراع بطبيعه الحال نتحول الى عثمان اي
فرح في واشنطن عثمان ونضرب موعد مع
المشاهدين غدا سنكون في تغطيه مباشره لهذه
الانتخابات النصفيه التي تعتبر حاسمه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لك عثمان
نعم اقتربنا جلال وستكون معنا انت طبعا
لمتابعه هذه النتائج اولا باول من كل
الولايات وبالذات من الولايات المتارجحه
التي سوف تحسم هذا سباق شكرا لك جلال اهلا
بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اذا ساعات المعدوده تفصيله عن موعد فتح
مركز الاقتراع في انحاء الولايات المتحده
ولنزال الانتخابيه جوانب اخرى اذ يخوض
الجمهوريون معارك قانونيه في عده ولايات
خصوصا المتارجحه لالغاء الاف بطاقات
التصويت البريد سعيا لتقليل الاستفاده
الديمقراطيين منها وقد تمكن الجمهوريون
بالفعل من حزم بعض هذه المعارك لصالحهم
قضائيا ما سيكون له تاثير على نتائج
الانتخابات
مع اقتراب يوم الاقتراع تحتاج معركه
التصويت بالبريد يعرف الجمهوريون ان اتباع
حزبهم يصوتون يوم الاقتراع ومع ذلك قاموا
بحمالات واسعه لاقناعهم بالتوجه بكثافه
اكبر الى مكاتب التصويت في المقابل يعرف
الجمهور دون ايضا ان نسبه كبيره من الشباب
والاقليات من اتباع الديمقراطيين يفضلون
التصويت عبر البريد لذلك يخوضون معارك
قانونيه عده لالغاء اكبر عدد ممكن من
الاصوات عبر البريد في ولايه متارجحه مع
العلم ان 40 مليون امريكي ادلوا باصواتهم
في الاقتراع المبكر في ولايه سلفانيا
وافقت المحكمه العليا على طلب الجمهوريين
بان لا تحتسب بطاقات اقتراع التي نسي
اصحابها كتابه التاريخ على الغلاف الخارجي
حتى لو وصلت طرد قبل يوم اقتراح وفي منشن
رفع الجمهوريون دعوه قضائيه ضد الهيئه
الانتخابيه لالغاء الاصوات الغيابيه التي
لم يدلى بها شخصيا مع بطاقه الهويه
واستهدفت بتروت التي تصوت للديمقراطيين
وتسكنها غالبيه من السود وليس ولايه
ميشيغان باكملها اما في وسكنسون فقد ربح
الجمهوريون الدعوه قضائيه استمعوا احتسابه
اصوات البريد التي لا يظهر فيها عنوان
الشاهد لان بعض الولايات تطلب توقيع شاهد
على التصويت وفي اتلانتا رفعت منظمه من
المجتمع المدني دعوى قضائيه لان النحو الف
تسويه غيابي لم يرسل بالبريد ونتج ذلك عن
قانون مرره الجمهوريون يقلل عدد الايام
التي يسمح فيها بارسال اقتراع بالبريد من
49 يوما الى 29 يوما هي طرق شتى اليها
الجمهوريون لتحديد اكبر عدد من اصوات
البريد خصوصا في الولايات المتارجحه ويمكن
ان يؤدي هذا الى تاخر كبير في عمليه فرز
الاصوات مع ما يرافق ذلك من توترات سياسيه
اصبحت تقلق الامريكيين فقد اظهر استطلاعه
للراي نشرات صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان النحو
تسعه من كل عشره امريكيه او 88 في المئه
من المستطاعين خليقون من ان الانقسامات
السياسيه قد اشتدت لدرجه يمكن ان تؤدي الى
اعمال عنف
في اعقاب جدل مستعر حول مدى قبول
الجمهوريين لنتائج الاقتراع قال الزعيم
الاقليه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي
سيعترفون بنتائج الانتخابات النصفيه لكنه
اضاف في لقاء مع شبكته سي ان انهم سيعملون
ايضا على التاكد من النزاهتها
سيعترف اعضاء مجلس النواب نتائج
الانتخابات
وسيتاكدون من انها اجريت بطريقه نزيهه
واتسائل ايضا مائده ستعترف كل من الى
ريكلنت ومرشحه الحزب ديمقراطي لمنصب حاكم
ولايه جورجيا ستيسي ابراهامز بالنتائج
ايضا اعتقد انني سافوز بمنصب رئيس مجلس
النواب وساحصل على دعم الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب
اما وزاره العدل الامريكيه فقد اعلنت
اليوم عن خطوطها لمراقبه الامتثال لقوانين
حقوق التصويت الفيدراليه في 64 دائره
انتخابيه في 24 ولايه وذكرت وزاره العدل
ان قسم الحقوق المدنيه سيتلاقى شكاوى من
الجمهور على مستوى البلاد فيما يتعلق
بالانتهاكات المحتمله لقوانين حقوق
التصويت واخرت الوزاره ان من بين
المراقبين موظفون من قسم الحقوق المدنيه
ومن مكاتب النيابه العامه في الملايات هذا
هو سينشر القسم مراقبين من مكتب اداره
شؤون الموظفين بامر من المحاكم الفيدراليه
كما سيبقى افراد القسمه على الاتصال مع
مسؤولي الانتخابات على مستوى الولايه
والمجالس المحليه
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو محلل الجزيره
لشؤون الانتخابات والقيادي في الحزب
الجمهوري وينضم الينا في الاستوديو جويل
روبن محلل الجزيره لشؤون الانتخابات
ومساعد وزير الخارجيه
الاسبق لشؤون الكونغرس والقياديه في الحزب
الديمقراطيه اهلا وسهلا بكما اقتربنا من
موعد الانتخابات اعتقد انكما متحمسان
المعارك الفضائيه التي تخاط فيما يخص
التصويت المبكر وخاصه التصويت بالبريد ما
الذي يحاول الجمهوريون فعله ماذا يعتقدون
ان هذا قد يكون في صالح
اعتقد ان هناك رغبه لضمان ان الاصوات التي
يجب ولا سعر الحل يحق لاصحابه التصويتيه
التي يجب ان تحسب بشكل عام لا اعتقد ان
هذا سيغير في النتيجه من شيء لان
القضاه
يترددون كثيرا في مثل هذه الامور وكل شخص
امريكي حق له التصويت يجب ان يحسب صوته
ومن لا يحق له لا يحسب صوته هذا هو الهدف
النهائي بان يتم حساب الاصوات القانونيه
المشروعه
هذه النقطه الجويه ليركز عليها الجمهوريون
يعني لا نسمع ان الديمقراطيين ياخذون
معارك قضائيه في ما يخص ابطال بطاقات
معينه لماذا
رائع نقترب من موعد الانتخابات
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه تزدهر الامريكيين
يريدون اختيار قادتنا المشكله هي الناس
ساسه يريدون ان يقولوا للناخبين اصواتكم
لم تحتسب
ودونالد ترامب في الانتخابات الماضيه قضوا
اياما اسابيع وهم يقولون اذا ما صوتهم عن
طريق المريضه بالتسويق المبكر اصواتكم لم
تحتسب وان نتيجه ستسرقم يحاولون ازاله
الشرعيه عن التصويت الديمقراطي لان
الديمقراطيط المبكر والتصويت البريدي هذا
مؤسف وهذا غير منصف ويناهض الروح
الامريكيه ونستفقه مع رون ان المحاكم
ستنظر في هذه الامور كما حصل في ان يقول
لكم تجاه هذه الدعوه القضائيه واستمر في
التصويت
الرون التشكيك في الانتخابات ونزاهاتها في
الحقيقه نسمعه اكثر بلا اي شك من
الجمهوريين ما تفعله وزاره العدل من انها
قالت انها ستراقب هذه الانتخابات وتتاكد
من النزاهاتها هل هذا يكفي بالنسبه لكم
التصويت المباشر عن طريق الاشخاص انا
عندما كنت رئيسا لفرع كاليفورنيا الحزب
الجمهوري كنا نشجع الناخبين لصوتوا في وقت
المبكر فلا غيره في ذلك لكن في النهايه
يفضلون التصويت المباشر طالما ان الكل
الصوتي يحسب وكل صوت
قانونيه طبعا
الذي بكره
نحن نعمل
في هذه الانتخابات
نعم ولكن اسال ايضا هل يكفي ما تقوم به
وزاره العدل يقتنع الجمهوريون المشككون
ويبدو احيانا كانهم يقولون ان المؤسسات
الدوله حتى تتامر عليه
هذه الانتخابات سرقت من هذا ليس امرا
جديدا طبعا القضيه كبرت لان الرئيس اعترض
على النتائج قبل عامين لكن قد نجد من يقول
هذا ويضخمه لكن في النهايه الامريكيه لا
يعرفون كيف يديرون انتخاباتهم والجمهورين
وديه يا جبان يثق بالنتيجه ربما سيكون في
النتيجه سيطر الجمهوريين على مجلس
الكونغرس لكن الجمهوريه يجب ان يكون
مقتنعين بضمان امني عمليات التصويت
رئيس الاقليه الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ
مقارسيه يقول ان الجمهوريه سوف يعترفون في
هذه النتائج ولكن ايضا يجب ان يتاكد من
النزاهتها هذا ليس مطمئنا الديمقراطيين
المتخوفين
مكاتي ذلك ويخطوه ايجابيه ال زعماء
جمهوريين يجب ان يقولوا ذلك وهم كانوا
بحازم يقتلوه على مدى عام ونصف نصرانه
وايضا الحاكم كندي لم يبينوا استعدادهم
الاحترام اراده الشعب
غيرهم
انكروا الفكره الفكره بان كل صوت هو صوت
حقيقي لانهم يخافون من الهزيمه امر جائز
ان يقول لك في المكانسه
من كل مرشح
جمهوريه وكل زعيم القراطيه يجب ان يقول
ذلك ويقبل نتيجه انتخابات 2020
شكرا لكم سوف يكون يوم الغد يوما طويلا
اتمنى لكم التوفيق جهل روبن من الحزب
الديمقراطي همم شكرا لك ايضا
القيادي في الحسبه الجمهوري شكرا جزيلا
تنضم تجمع انتخابي لمرشحين الجمهوريين في
مدينه فينيكس في ولايه اريزونا مراسله
الجزيره بيسان
انت ليست بعيده عن الحدود وفي هذه
الولايه تحديدا يركز الجمهوريون كثيره عن
همم على ملف الهجره وعندما اقول الحدود
طبعا يعني الحدود الامريكيه المكسيكيه
بالفعل عثمان نحن امام هذا التجمع
للمرشحه لمنصب حاكمه الولايه كاريليكوبليك
المرشح لمقعد مجلس الشيوخ والهجره هو
عنوان اخر حملاتهم الانتخابيه طبعا قبل
بدء الاقتراع يوم غد
في الاستطلاعات ليك تتقدم على منافسات هذه
الديمقراطيه مع استاذ
يفصله بنقطه واحده عن منافسه هذه
ولكن ما يقولها هؤلاء المرشحون هو ان
الديمقراطيون يريدون حدودا مفتوحه همم لك
تتعهد باستكمال الجدار الحدودي الذي كان
قد بناه ترامب وتوقف الان مع طبعا همم
يتسلم اداره الان ايضا همم الديمقراطيون
من الجهه الاخرى يحاولون استمالات اصوات
اللاتيني في ظل طبعا بعض
الهج او هذا الخطاب الحاد من الجمهوريين
ضد الديمقراطيين بانهم ضعيفين جدا فيما
يتعلق بملف الهجره وكان هناك استثمار من
الحسبه الديمقراطي لهذه الجاريه ثلث
الاميركيين من اصول اللاتينيه في هذه
الولايه يميلون الى الديمقراطين وهم
يشكلون كل سكان هذه الولايه ويعول عليهم
الديمقراطيون في الحصول على اصوات مكرهم
من المحافظه على مقعدهم في مجلس الشيوخ
وربما ايضا الفوز بمنصب حاكمته الولايه
على العموم انا كنت قد قعدت تقريرا حول
قضيه امن الحدود وهذا السجال المحتدل جدا
في هذه الولايه الحدوديه وزرنا المناطق
الحدوديه ما بين اريزونا والمكسيك لي
نتابعه معنا
هذه هي حدود ولايه اريزونا مع المكسيك
وهنا تقع مزرعه جون لاد للمواشي
السابق
ان ذلك خفف من نسبه العابرين من الجهه
الاخرى لكن الواقعه تغير مع تسلم الرئيس
جوبايدن السلطه حسب قوله وبعد ذلك يؤثر في
واقع الحالي بمزرعته
ثم يستخدمه المياه
على طول هذه الحدود يحاول المهاجرون
القادمين من الجهه الاخرى البحث عن فجوات
او سياجا منخفضا للدخول الى الولايات
المتحده منذ مطلع العام سجل حرس الحدود
اكثر من مليونين محاوله عبور وفق استطلاع
لمؤسسه كيو يعتبر 91% من الجمهوريين
والمستقلين الذين يميلون لهم تامين الحدود
هدفا مهما مقابل 59% من الديمقراطيين
والمستقلين الذين يميلون لهم
نحن على الجبهه الاماميه في قضيه الحدود
المفتوحه الحدود المفتوحه لا تساعد احدا
ولا تعني اننا متسامحون هناك التجار
بالبشر واستغلال وزياده في المعاناه
والعصابات مستفيده
ان الجمهوريين في حديثهم عن تامين الحدود
لا يفهمون ابدا العيش في منطقه حدوديه ليس
كل ما يحدث غير قانوني اؤيد تامين الحدود
لاننا لا نريد المخدرات والتجاره للبشر
لكن ليس بسبب سعي شخص للهجره الى هنا
صعد الجمهوريون منها هجماتهم على اداره
بيض ليصفوا ما يحدث بالازمه الحدوديه وبدا
منذ مطلع العام حكام جمهوريون لولايات
تكساس وفلوريدا ومعهم حاكم اريزونا ارسال
حافلات محمله بالمهاجرين الى مدن يسيطر
عليها ديمقراطيون في الساحل الشرقيه من
البلاد كي يتحملوا هم العباده
ممارسه يصفها الديمقراطيون والناشطون في
مجال الهجره بانها غير انسانيه
رسمت الصوره على ان قدوم المهاجرين هو غزو
وهذا غير صحيح وثانيا يقولون ان اولئك
المهاجرين الاتيين هم مجرمون وهذا غير
صحيح كنت اتطوع مع تلك العائلات وهم اشخاص
عاديون لذا انا قليقه لان ما يقال هو
معلومات مغلوطه وهذا لن يساعد احدا
وتبايني مقاربه المرشحين الجمهوريين
وديمقراطيين في اريزونا اذا التعامل مع
ملف الهجره فان هناك توافقا بان الوضع
الحالي لا يمكن ان يستمر بسان ابو كويك
الجزيره فينيكس اريزونا
وبهذا طبعا التقرير كنا شملنا الخطاب الذي
نسمعه من الجمهوريين ومن الديمقراطين فيما
يتعلق بقضيه الحكم الحدود المفتوحه عثمان
كما يقول الجمهوريون واعلان كاريك انها
تريد اعلان ما يحدث على الحدود الامريكيه
مع المكسيك حدود ولايه ارينا همم ما
ستسميه الغزو ستعلن ان ما يحدث هناك انه
غزو على هذه الحدود وسيضها ذلك في مواجهه
مباشره مع الحكومه الفيدراليه طبعا
والاداره الامريكيه في واشنطن عثمان
شكرا شكرا لك بيسان من اريزونا وسنتابع
معك ومع الزملاء الانتخابات بعد ساعات
يعني نتحدث عن الغد اقل من 24 ساعه سوف
يكون يوم طويلا شكرا لك من فيلم ابو كويك
ومشاهدين من الملف الهجره الى تطور اخر
متصل بامن الانتخابات النصفيه والجدل
الدائره حول التدخلات الاجنبيه فيها قال
رجل الاعمال من الرئيس الروسي وهو اا ديني
دركوش اليوم قال انه تدخل في الانتخابات
الامريكيه وانه سيواصل فعل ذلك مستقبلا
واضاف في منشور على موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الروسي في كي انه سيواصل التدخل
بشكل دقيق وبطريقته الخاصه على حد تعبيره
ويخضع عقوبات امريكيه اوروبيه وهو متهم
منذ سنوات بالتدخل في الانتخابات
الامريكيه
وفي رد فعل على الدعاءات بريكوزن قال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه نت بريس
خلال مؤتمر صحفي انما قاله رجل الاعمال
الروسي بشان التدخل في الانتخابات
الامريكيه ليس بجديد على واشنطن انه يخضع
لعقوبات امريكيه منذ اعوام واضاف ان
التصريح مظهر من مظاهر افلات المقربين من
الكرملين من المحاسبه
تونسي
من المحاسبه التي يتمتع بها المفسدون في
عهد الرئيس بوتين والمقربون من الكرم لقد
سبق وفرضنا عقوبات على هذا الشخص منذ عام
28 لتدخله في عملياتنا ومؤسساتنا
الانتخابيه
ينضم الينا دكتور خليل العناني محلل
الجزيره للجزيره لشؤون الانتخابات النصفيه
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
سعد بلقائك اهلا دكتور هل يفاجئك هذا
التصريح انه علنا يقول هذا الرجل نعم
تدخلته
وساتدخل على الاطلاق
روسيه للضغط على امريكا خاصه في اطار
النفسي حرب النفسيه بالاساس خاصه في ظل
وجود عقوبات امريكيه نتيجه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا وبالتالي ان يخرج اليوم
جيبوجين يتحدث هذه الطريقه هو يحاول ان
يطفي مزيد من الاثار على الانتخابات
الامريكيه هناك قناعه امريكيه بين روسيا
تتدخل بشكل او فقط تدخل في 2016 حوالي في
2020 وهتحول الان وبالتالي يجوز انها حرب
نفسي اكثر هل ثبت اي شيء من هذا طبعا كان
هناك حديث كثير عن التدخل الصيني ولكن هل
ثبت انه كانت هناك تدخل بالفعل حتى هذه
اللحظه ليس هناك التقرير ذات مصداقيه
عاليه حول وجود تدخل روسي بشكل يؤثر على
نتيجه الانتخابات هناك محاولات هناك جيوش
الكترونيه
المعلومات زيها وهناك استعداد للاسف
الشديد في امريكا للاستماع لهذه الاخبار
الكاذبه والمزيفه خاصه داخل الحزب
الجمهوري هناك قبول من وزاره المؤامره
هناك قبول بانه الانتخابات غير نزيهه
وهناك نوع من التزوير وبالتالي ويحاول ان
يلعب على هذه الحاله النفسيه داخل حزب
جمهور كي يوفر نتيجه انتخابات اللاعب
اعتقد بشكل عام هناك تاثير كبير حتى هذه
لحظه على الاقل فيما يتعلق مصليات
الانتخابات
ايضا يشككون من خلال هذا الرجل ايضا
ويصفونه بطباخ الرئيس طبعا طبق الرئيس
يتحدثون على همم التدخل وليس له علاقه
بالاكل يعني كما كان فيلم طلعت زكريا الله
يرحمه في الفيلم الشهير هو رجل مؤثر جدا
وهناك ايضا المطالبات امريكيه يعني هناك
مكافاه مقصوده له 10 مليون دولار لمن زي
معلومات حول هذا الرجل لانه تدخل في
الحدود 2016 هو ايضا مطلوب لقضايا اخرى
متعلقه انه مؤسس له مرتزقه من الاشياء
التي لا لا نشاط كبير جدا سواء في افريقيا
في ليبيا في سوريا وحتى في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي هو مطلوب
اعلى ريحه العداله الامريكيه بشكل
الموضوع في ما يتعلق برج الاعمال الروسي
هذا لا يقتصر على موضوع التدخل في
الانتخابات عن طريق وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وما شابه ذلك ولكن هو اكبر من
ذلك بكثير طبعا بلا شك كما قلت قبل قليل
ومطلوب لاسباب متعلقه سواء بالانتخابات
الامريكيه السابقه في 2016 تحديدا هناك
طبعا كان لجنه التحقيق هذه الانتخابات
ل- اا يعني بتوجيه التهامات وهنا التهابات
بالفعل الموجهه له هو الاخرين كان نقدر
هناك له دور اصلا كمان في ستات خارجيه
الروسيه هناك دور مهم جدا انك اعتقاد بان
فاجنر مموله بشكل اوخر او متعام من الكرم
وبالتالي هو يكون بدور مهم جدا في هذه من
الشيكات من اجل ان يؤثر على اساسات
الخارجيه الامريكيه في المنطقه في الشرق
الاوسط بشكل عام وخاصه في حرب داخل
اوكرانيا حاليا كثير من المرشحين
الجمهوريين يشككون همم مسبقا في نتائج
الانتخابات وقد يعني ويقولون ان
الانتخابات الماضيه الرئاسيه كانت مسروقه
او يعني فيها الكثير من الغش ولكن اليوم
سمعنا كابور همم مكارثي وهو رئيس القريه
الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ يقول انهم
سيعترفون
سيعترفون انهم يعتقدون ان هناك فوز كبير
للجمهوريين وبالتالي وهم يعرفون مسبقا ان
هذه الانتخابات تستثم شكله وباخر في
صالحهم وبالتالي من الصعب عدم كوبري تاج
الانتخابات لكن ايضا هناك بعض التخوف في
بعض الولايات مثلا الدوايات متراجحه
اريزونا جورجيا نيفادا ما يخاف منه عدم
يعني ظهور الانتخابات بشكل سريع ممكن
الانتخابات بشكل سريع في هذه المساله لكن
بشكل عام اعتقد هناك شعور جمهور بالارتياح
هناك اقبالنا او اعمال قناه سوف يحصلون
على الاغلبيه سواء في مجلس النواب او مجلس
الشيوخ شكرا دكتور خالد العلاني محل
الجزيره لشؤون الانتخابات النصفيه استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه بخلاف
ما هو معمول به في دول العدد تقع مسؤوليه
تنظيم الانتخابات والاشراف عليها في
الولايات المتحده على عاتق السلطات
المحليه وقد اكتسب المسؤولون عن
الانتخابات اهميه اضافيه مع استمرار
التشكيك كما كنا نتحدث في نتائج انتخابات
الرئاسيه الاخيره والجدل بشان الاجراءات
المختلفه التي يرى بعض انها تضيق على
المشاركه بينما يراها بعض الاخر ضمانه
لنزاهه عمليه الاقتراع مراسلنا فادي منصور
يستعرض في التقرير التالي الجهات التي
تنظم الانتخابات ودورها وصلاحياتها
تتسم اداره الانتخابات في الولايات
المتحده بلا مركزيه واسعه وقوانين
الولايات الا القانون الفيدرالي تنظم معظم
نواحي عمليات الاقتراع والانتخابات
بمستوياتها المختلفه سواء الفدراليه او
على نطاق الولايه او محليا تدخل ضمن
اختصاص السلطات المحليه
تتولى سلطات الولايات مسؤوليه الجوانب
الاداريه للعمليه الانتخابيه
واجراءات الاقتراع واختيار اساليبه
وتقرروا بشان اهليه الناخبين وتحدد
متطلبات اثبات الهويه بما ينسجم مع
القانون الفيدرالي بالاضافه الى تامين
انظمه الاقتراع ومراكز المقتنعين في 25
ولايه امريكيه يجري انتخابه سكرتير
للولايات لهذا الغرب بينما طنيت الولايات
الاخرى مسؤوليه اداره العمليه الديمقراطيه
بنواب الحكام او مسؤولين عن الانتخابات
تعينهم المجالس التشريعيه للولايات او
حكمها او بمفاوضات انتخابيه
يتولى المسؤول عن الانتخابات او الهيئه
المعنيه بها التصديق على الاقتراع
والاشراف على فرز الاصوات وابلاغ النتائج
لسلطات الولايه ويعود الاهتمام بهذا
المنصب في الانتخابات النصفيه
26 جمهوريه على منصب سكرتير الولايات من
بينهم 20 مرشحا شككو في نتائج الانتخابات
الاخيره
ورغم السلطات الواسعه التي يتمتع بها
سكرتير الولايه فان هذا الموقع تحكم
دساتير الولايات والقوانين والانتخابيه
فضلا عن الدور التحكيمي الذي يقوم به
القضاء
نهايه هذه النافذه من واشنطن ولكن طبعا
نحن مستمرون معكم في المتابعه او سوف تكون
معكم ال سي ابي عاصي في نشره منتصف الليل
اما الان فنعود الى جلال شهد في الدوحه
جلال
[موسيقى]
قانون الحصاده بارقام صادمه اودت موجات
الحر ب 15000 شخص على الاقل في اوروبا هذا
العام وفقنا اعلنته منظمه الصحه العالميه
اليوم اسبانيا والمانيا كانتال اكثر تاثرا
وكانت الشهور الثلاثه من حزيران يونيو حتى
اب اغسطس الاكثر حراره في اوروبا منذ بدء
تسجيل البيانات وتسببت درجات الحراره
المرتفعه بشكل استثنائي في اسوا موجه جفاف
شهدتها القاره منذ العصور الوسطى واثرت
موجات الحر على المحاصيل في اوروبا بينما
ازدادت حده حرائق الغابات كما تفاقم الضغط
على شبكات الطاقه في القاره هو مشهد اردنا
ان نتوقف عنده معكم قبل ان نشكركم على حسن
المتابعه الى اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]